pour lui
[Musique]
jean françois archambault bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chef nous est presque
père noël aujourd'hui parce qu'on est en
direct c'est l'atelier du père noël
derrière vous qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous emballez c'est
vraiment le projet des coffrets
solidaire
c'est un projet qui émane des enjeux
qu'on vit pendant la colline
l'enjeu principal c'est la perte de
revenus liée
normalement nous soirée-bénéfice les
grandes tablées qu'on fait à l'automne
toujours au château frontenac et au
reine élizabeth et où on amasse près
d'un demi million $ nets pour financer
nos activités d'éducation qui venant
chez les jeunes dans les écoles et de
récupération de surplus alimentaires ni
l'hôtellerie de la restauration services
alimentaires vers les banques
alimentaires et des organismes
normalement qui avait donc on a perdu
près de 200 mille dollars de revenus
liées à ces événements là parce qu'on a
dû les faire en mode virtuel puis les
gens étaient je dirais pas moins au
rendez-vous mais lens plus de gens et là
donc les entreprises vous encourage en
achetant ces boîtes là et ça vous permet
de récupérer combien de votre
financement habituel à peu près si on
vend tous les paniers tous les coffrets
on va récupérer 100%
bravo donc l'idée c'était ça c'est à
dire combien on a besoin d'en faire pour
y arriver
puis le chiffre magique c'était 3500 les
chefs ont reçu les produits les matières
premières que qu'on a commandée nous
mêmes qu'on a reçue en don pour la
plupart d'agriculteurs qui nous ont
donné des oignons des betteraves des
dunes avait et on a créé des produits
solidaires on leur a demandé de faire
inviter la jeunesse un contenu de grande
qualité de 30 au niveau des exemples de
des produits offerts en jasant avec
frédérique cyr le chef du château
frontenac
je ne s'attendent plus de faire une
confiture d'oignons intrus qui dit jeudi
sur plus de 1000
j'ai pas pu on met des pots de miel dans
presque toutes les chambres pour les
cadeaux dans dans la rue peel auteur n'a
pas été occupé dont qui ont des surplus
de miers les villes tant qu'à faire
quelque chose d'autre et je vais te
mettre en pot le miel du château après
on est allé vers un yves l'eau le chef
du centre bell qui on récupère normand
tous les surplus des matchs des
canadiens les loges on nourrit plus de
cent mille personnes par année avec les
surplus de bouffe des loges et on nous
demandera et vivent normalement du pop
corn z4 de faire ça au centre bell
peux tu nous faire un pop corn bio à
l'érable on va t'envoyer le sirop
d'érable qu'on a demandé à citadelle en
commandite nous ont donné le sirop et il
s'est amusé à pop et du pop corn puis à
nous faire une petite chaudière de
pointe fait que c'est tout des
collaborations comme ça avec nos chefs
avec lesquels les chefs sont si généreux
avec nous on va pas les deux aspects
l'aspect de de donner le goût aux jeunes
dans les écoles dans des milieux
défavorisés en train de cuisiner pas de
devenir chef mais de l'espèce de respect
que les aliments vous rejoignez combien
de jeunes par année combien le monde on
a rejoint plus aujourd'hui le plus de
3000 jeunes principalement milieux
défavorisés mais dans tous les milieux
et même jusqu'en côte nord
en résidence en iran ni temps ni
autochtone aussi pour la première fois
depuis l'année dernière
[Musique]
l'autonomie alimentaire devrait
développer chez tous les jeunes
devraient être quelque chose
d'accessible comme le théâtre le basket
ou faire partie de la troupe de théâtre
de l'école ou de l'équipe de sport de
son école donc valorisé l'alimentation
retrouvé la place pour la cuisine et
l'alimentation dans l'école pour les
jeunes qui a kiss à leurs plats parle
d'avantagé où ils vont pouvoir exprimer
leur leadership dans ce créneau lot
l'autre aspect important vous en parler
plus des bus et les surplus cette idée
de dire on va prendre vous ai parlé des
surplus de centre bell on va parler
surplus des hôtels des restaurants et on
va faire quelque chose avec
et est ce que ça marche est ce que les
années ont prouvé que ça marche et ça
marche très très bien en fait un créneau
qu'on avait sous-estimé puis que mon
équipe a travaillé très fort c'est le
secteur hospitalier
qui aurait prédit que présentement on
pourrait garder en vie notre programme
de récupération alimentaire parce qu'on
récupère les surplus alimentaires des
cafétérias et des services alimentaires
en milieu hospitalier est que plus d'une
quarantaine de centres hospitaliers au
québec
récup'art leur souffle et alimentaires
sur une base quotidienne donc on peut
nourrir près d'un demi million de
personnes seulement par ce programme là
en secteur hospitalier et la
constellation d'organismes
communautaires qui reçoivent sur fond
quoi avec ça en fait
e on travaille principalement avec des
organismes qui servent des repas sur
place donc heureux servent ces aliments
de leur travail en recettes vont prendre
une purée de pommes de terre vont leur
travail et d'une autre façon vont
prendre un ris qui a été récupéré sur
quelques semaines qui a été congelé et
ils vont au travail et une autre cette
donc souvent c'est y font des miracles
en fait c'est infrastructures là cette
logistique loges avaient mis sur pied ce
que ça fait d'être sillage
on fait de la récupération avec les
rappeurs les mets police au sco chemin
que rina dans les loges on est au bien
m'offrir d'aussi pour les matches du
toronto fc et on est à vancouver au
rogers arena avec les canucks de
vancouver
on a préparé quatre cent mille repas à
l'extérieur du québec avec le rogers
arena et le cette semaine on commence à
préparer des repas avec le sco chopin
corinne annonce a commencé dès commencé
des chiffres impressionnants
vous avez une vous avez tendu vraiment
vos tentacules ça ça fait du monde qui
sont touchés par ce que vous faites
beaucoup c'est sûr que on a pu mobiliser
les chefs les cuisiniers c'est clair que
ça ne se crée un une infrastructure qui
est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus percutante
quand il ya des enjeux comme la pandémie
pour nourrir des millions de personnes
mais je pense moi ce que je trouve le
plus triste présentement je le vois pas
ce que j'ai tous mes amis sont dans leur
restaurant on sent dans l'industrie et
je pense que il faut avoir une pensée
pour nos chefs
nos cuisiniers tout ce que ça va faire à
l'industrie de la restauration
c'est grave quand même et c'est ce
concessionnaire affecté nos activités
parce que si à moins qu'ils signé il ya
moins de chefs ya moins d'établissements
je pense qu'on va reculer sur sur notre
culture le développement notre culture
gastronomique et lé alimentaire mais il
va falloir un geste de solidarité
une fois que l'on va être des confiné
pour vraiment aller soutenir le secteur
de la restauration qui nous ont soutenus
et qui nous a permis de faire ce qu'on
fait présentement on vous le souhaite
pour 2021 tout qu'on se souhaite à tous
merci beaucoup jean françois mercier non
mais très apprécié merci